No.
Well
it depends on what you describe as big
media is Google big media now.
I mean they're worth more than most of
the other media companies.
There was a period of time when most of
the cable companies,
they were worth more,
at least in Wall Street market cap terms
and then the broadcast networks.
It seems in media that no one ever
really goes away.
It's when something new comes out
eventually,
first of all,
people say,
Oh,
you know,
TV's going to kill radio and then cable
TV is going to kill tv and you know this
or that,
or the other thing is going to always
kill something off.
Somehow everybody moves over on the
bench and nothing really goes away.
I mean some formats might go away like
the eight track or the cassette or the
LP,
but the idea pretty much continues and
in the end,
the big media companies,
which facial lot of challenges now,
I mean you're talking about the
traditional TV,
cable TV companies,
they,
they face a lot of challenges from the
new media.
They will eventually morph into that
world,
be bought by a new media company by one,
and turn will still find ways to
participate.
It's going to be hard.
I think it's naive to think that these
companies are going to crumble and fall
away.
I mean,
they're going through a very tough
transition now as our people in any
industry that has to deal with the
digitization of anything.
But at the end of the day,
there'll be a bunch of large companies,
pretty much controlling a good amount of
what goes on.
That seems to be,
you know,
the way of our capitalist system.
That's not to say that the small
independent voices still won't be out
there and be able to be heard,
but,
but the mass market,
as it as however you wanna define it,
uh,
will be reachable largely,
probably through bigger.